let's take a look at some of the
research projects that the students have
carried out using python so here we have
a cohort of students from Georgetown
University who had carried out a diverse
range of research projects on topics
ranging from infectious diseases
metabolic disorders Neuroscience
psychiatric disorders and so on for
example Rohan Harris he is using python
to identify different expression of
genes and asymptomatic and symptomatic
covid-19 patients by Genta and then we
also have Rhema who's carrying out her
project on metabolic disorders where she
is trying to build relationship machine
learning models for accurate prediction
of whether the individual has diabetes
or not and then we have Jordan Henry who
is carrying out a predictive model for
post chemotherapy neurodegeneration
Based on rnac data and then we also have
an ongoing project by Michelle beat
who's carrying out gene expression
changes in at-risk and diagnose PTSD
patients to identify potential
treatments so all of these are some of
the ongoing python projects that are
there I would also like to show some of
the completed projects that are there on
the portal so for example Simpson has
carried out a independent research
project on brain tumor subtype
exploration for candidate biomarkers I'm
sharing the link in the chat boxes
project that participants can take a
look at and go through
and then we also have yunju who has
carried out unsupervised clustering and
multiple classes of opioid use using
python I'm sharing the link to her
research project as well
and then we have a PhD student who
carried out an independent research
project on random forest classifier for
back curious and classification so all
of these are some of the various
research projects that have been carried
out using python so where can you find
more of such projects on the portal that
let me take you to the portal once again
and show you
so here when you
um go to the courses tab next to it
you'll also see a tab that says projects
so once you click on this
it will show you the various projects
that other students have done and this
could be in various Fields such as
oncology infectious diseases as I
described so the participants can take a
look at the various projects that the
students have carried out in this link
and uh with that I'd like to pass on the
stage to sonalika for those participants
who are interested to enroll for the
program so the stage is always
and a very warm good morning or good
evening to all of you present here
now I would like to show you all how you
can register yourself for the program
biomedical data science in Python so
here is the link to the program page
that you need to visit to to register
yourself for the program
it's in the chat box now once you're on
the program page if you scroll down you
can first of all find the schedule of
the program which tells how many
interactive sessions we are going to
have you have the lender with the dates
are marked also you have all the
information here presented here for all
the topics that would be covered and the
coding lessons that you have to go
through as a part of each and every
session
now these coding lessons are such
lessons that Dr raghav took you through
from the python coursework that you have
to follow along which has got the
concepts the logic the syntax and the
practice sessions you have to submit
your assignments and complete the
quizzes in these coding lessons so one
session will involve one mental guided
live session that you will have and you
need to complete these coding lessons as
well now the question that was raised uh
in the chat uh regarding not being
available during the duration of the
program so I want to mention that for
such people who are not available at the
time of the live session let's say or at
the duration of the program they can
follow the program asynchronously that
means you can go along the session
recording the session recording the
mentor session recording would be
uploaded on the program page itself when
the session is completed to give you an
example I'll take you you to another
ongoing program so once the session is
completed we put the recording of the
session on the program page itself once
you enrolled you will be a part of the
program page where you can watch the
recording and go through the resources
once you complete the session you click
on complete session button and you are
good to go or proceed ahead all right so
for those who are not available
uh at the time of the live session you
can watch the recording you can watch
the recording and take your questions
um via email or we are also going to
form a Skype chat group we'll have a
Skype chat group set up for all the
participants in the program you can ask
your question in that group from the
mentor if Skype chat is not suitable we
can also have a WhatsApp group where you
can ask your questions and we'd be glad
to assist you we'll also have some live
q a sessions in between me so maybe you
can try joining those sessions all right
so that was all about schedule and how
you can manage attending the sessions or
going through the recordings now when
you scroll down you will find all the
details of each and every session on
which days they are scheduled they are
generally scheduled on Tuesdays and
Fridays of the month of uh in the month
of January and you have the topics that
we'll cover and also the coding lessons
are mentioned here that will be
following around
the program has got 14 sessions two
sessions every week and we'll be closing
the program on March 10th so that was
about the schedule now how do you
register yourself so when you scroll
down you can see three different types
of subscription levels that you can pick
to enroll yourself in the program one is
45 days another one is 60 days and then
you have the 90 days of the program
duration
now here the different slides in how you
can proceed from completing the training
program to completing a research project
so in the 45 days you will get the
access to all the mentor guided live
sessions and then you'll also uh go
through each one of these resources that
are mentioned on the program page that I
showed up and then on in the 60 days of
the subscription level you will get
one-on-one mental support to prepare a
research proposal that you can further
work uh as a research project that could
be published and in the 90 days of the
subscription level you will be able to
complete a research project and have it
published so the difference in these
three diff different subscription levels
just lies in the time period I'll say or
the duration you get extra time period
to work on the research project or a
research question applying the skill set
that you learn or gain from the specific
training program
now uh the pricing here is mentioned in
dollars if you are not from us but a
different country you can scroll up and
change the
pricing let's say I'm in India right now
so the currency would be INR I can
change the currency to INR and then it
would be easy for me to understand what
the pricing looks like right now we are
offering some good scholarships uh so
those who are interested to enroll in
the program can reach out to us on
marketing either atomicslogic.com so
that we can share the coupon code with
you applying which you will get a good
scholarship on the program
has shared the uh scholarship code
already in the program which is python
50 which will give you a 50 scholarship
uh you can save it with you and then
proceed with your enrollment